حسنًا، تعاني إسرائيل من
الحادث الأكثر دموية لجيشها
منذ غزوها لغزة في أواخر
أكتوبر، وكانت هذه هي الجنازة التي أقيمت في
وقت سابق اليوم لواحد من 21 جنديًا
قتلوا يوم الاثنين في انفجار
بالقرب من حدود إسرائيل مع غزة.  من
المحتمل أن تكون المتفجرات التي
كان الجنود يزرعونها لهدم
مبنيين انفجرت بشكل غير متوقع بعد أن
أصيبت دبابة كانت تحمي الجنود
بقذيفة آر بي جي، ووصف رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي ذلك
بأنه أحد أصعب أيام
الصراع، ونحني رؤوسنا لذكرى
شهدائنا  ومع ذلك، فإننا لا نتوقف
لحظة عن السعي لتحقيق
هدف لا يمكن تعويضه، وهو تحقيق
النصر المطلق معًا سنقاتل ومعًا
سننتصر، كل هذا عملنا من أجل
وقف إطلاق النار، ويستمر محلل سي إن إن يقول
المسؤولون الإسرائيليون متفائلون بشأن وقف إطلاق النار لمدة
شهرين  اتفاق وقف إطلاق النار المقدم
لحماس من خلال مصر ومركز سي إن إن
علمت أيضًا أن إسرائيل اقترحت
السماح لكبار قادة حماس
بمغادرة غزة كجزء من
اتفاق وقف إطلاق النار الأوسع. ينضم إلينا أليكس ماركارت
من واشنطن مع تفاصيل أليكس، لقد
كسرت تلك القصة الثانية.  بالنسبة لنا
هذا الصباح، أعطونا المزيد من الأفكار حول
ما تنطوي عليه وما هو رد الفعل الذي
كان جيدًا حتى الآن. لقد سمعنا منذ ما يقرب من أربعة
أشهر
مسؤولين إسرائيليين كبار يقولون إن الهدف من هذه
الحرب هو النصر الكامل على حماس، إنها
القضاء على حماس.  لكن من الواضح أن الضغط
يتزايد على نتنياهو
وحكومته للتوصل إلى نوع من
أه صفقة لإطلاق سراح الرهائن
وهذا على الأرجح سيترتب عليه أه
وقف إطلاق النار ما قيل لي أحد
المقترحات الجديدة أه
المخابرات الإسرائيلية  لقد اقترح الرئيس ديفيد بارنيا
على نظيره الأمريكي
مدير وكالة المخابرات المركزية بيل بيرنز أن هذا الأمر قد
أثير أيضا في الأسابيع القليلة الماضية أه
للوزير يومض أه عندما كان
يزور قطر هو أن قادة حماس
في جي يمكن أن يغادروا قطاع غزة أه لكن
هذا سيكون  من الواضح أن هذا سيفيد إسرائيل
أيضًا، فهو سيضعف حماس في
قطاع غزة، وسيجذبهم بشكل أساسي للخروج
من الأنفاق، وإذا ذهبوا إلى
مكان آخر، فمن المؤكد أن إسرائيل
ستستهدفهم في مكان آخر، ونحن نعلم أن
إسرائيل تخطط لإقامة معسكر
لحملة عالمية لاستهداف حماس.  القادة في جميع أنحاء
العالم أه قتلوا قائدًا كبيرًا في حماس
في بيروت في وقت سابق أه هذا الشهر
لذلك هذا شيء
قيد المناقشة وهو حقًا يتحدث عن
الضغط الذي يشعر به نتنياهو
ويتحدث أيضًا عن عدم التقدم
الذي أحرزته إسرائيل  ضد حماس في
هذه الأشهر الأربعة الماضية كبار
قادة حماس في غزة ومنهم يحيى
سنيرم ومحمد ديف وهو
القائد العسكري أه ما زالوا على قيد الحياة
مع كبار نوابهم أه حوالي
70% من قوة حماس المقاتلة لا تزال
موجودة  ساحة المعركة حسب
تقديرات إسرائيل الخاصة لذلك هذا اقتراح تم
طرحه أم لكنه شيء
لا يتوقع أن تقبله حماس
نتنياهو أه آسف بلينكن قيل ذلك
أه في لقائه في الدوحة و وفي
محادثات مع مسؤولينا
الدوليين  أيها المسؤولون، لقد قيل لي إن
السينور وديف وآخرين هؤلاء
مؤمنون حقيقيون، هؤلاء أيديولوجيون،
هؤلاء أشخاص إذا كانوا
سيموتون فإنهم يريدون الموت وهم يقاتلون أه
عدوهم اللدود ولكن أبعد من ذلك لا يزال من
الرائع النظر في حقيقة أن
إسرائيل  حتى أه أسمح أو أو أو
أفكر في السماح لهؤلاء المسؤولين
بمغادرة غزة فنعم، هذا يعطيك حالة
من التوتر داخل
الحكومة الإسرائيلية هناك ومجلس
الوزراء الحربي حول إلى أين تتجه هذه الحرب
وما هي احتمالات أه
الانتهاء  مع
عودة جميع الرهائن إلى المنزل عاجلاً وليس آجلاً،
شكرًا لك أليكس ماركوارت